jon jones and greg jackson because
uh you know
you for the stories you were talking
about with greg jackson on on mental
toughness like some of the stuff is
psychotic like when you were saying on
joe rogan you carry your guy in and you
have to be willing to die you know for
your buddies and to go through this
when when john came through you're the
older brother to him right you were
playing because you were the guy that
ran the camp and you made the camp
popular everybody knew you were that
name right and in this world camps are
very important right
great coach gets a great player that
player can also make the coach very
famous in sports college tim duncan made
pop pretty famous michael made
feel very famous kobe didn't really make
feel famous because phil was already
famous but michael made feels famous
right uh
how how was john's energy when he came
in because i've heard what you've said
about him before
and i you know the interview you guys
did together with it wasn't joe was
somebody else interviewing the two of
you guys before the fight you know what
i'm talking about and then i've seen
daniel cormier and him talk and what
daniel says about john where he says
he'll never change you don't make
mistakes over and over and over again
etc etc you you hear that whole
conversation with joe was i think
hosting that interview
who was
john when he first walked into the camp
who was that guy
he was an eager student you know john
just wanted to learn um
very big imagination you know uh he
would he would uh you know after
training he'd be one of those guys who
would just sit and just you know uh play
around and kind of just uh you know try
out different moves like just you know
like these different um you know
conceptual moves you know things that
you may never pull off but he'll do
those things over and over again things
that people wouldn't expect a very big
imagination um very eager to uh to be
the guy you know i remember we went out
one time and he's like oh man what is it
like to have you know people come up to
you and want to take pictures and i'm
like one day you'll find out you know
you know it's so super ambitious very
ambitious curious was he humble
um yeah he was humble he was confident
but confident very confident so he had
swagger even coming in oh yeah he he
wanted he wanted he wanted to be um he
wanted to be the guy and he knew he one
day he would be how old was he when you
first met him
maybe 21 maybe 21 yeah and so when you
guys were sparring did you
when you're practicing did you say
this guy's different like did you
immediately feel that this guy's
different than everybody else yeah yeah
i remember um we were doing we're doing
uh we're doing
wrestling we were doing wrestling i used
to take everybody down
and uh and i went with him for the first
time and i'm like all right i'll go and
he took me down and i was like first
time first time and i was like oh yeah
i mean he's been wrestling his brothers
his whole life two nfl players
and he's the skinniest in the family
so he was six four one seventy in junior
year yeah he he's got he's got a freaky
dimension that kind of adds to
you know his athleticism and what he's
able to do in the octagon
was he was he a troublemaker before or
did he pick up the habits after all the
attention came
um you know i i would say that you know
john is uh
i wouldn't say a troublemaker i would
just say that he would um
what gets john in trouble is because
every four four weeks before his fight
he likes to blow off a little bit of
steam and it's kind of like his ritual
that he does where you know he wants to
um you know it's like a little
celebration to himself you know and it's
kind of like his thing where you know
he'll go and he'll party like four weeks
before he fights and then he uh finished
the rest of his camp
you know but when he goes he goes hard
you know what i'm saying he goes hard in
the paint yeah but blow off a little
literally a little too literally yeah a
little too literally but was that like
was it what i'm trying to find out is
like you know sometimes uh i had i
interviewed billy bean we had him at the
event billy bean i don't know if you've
seen a movie moneyball with uh uh brad
pitt you know the baseball movie if
you've seen it and i said billy you're a
recruiter when you're recruiting guys
what are you looking for he says
obviously talent okay
physical like what you what you look
like physically you take care of
yourself
and then he said
a work ethic and then he said upbringing
an upbringing is
if we don't have that that's tough
because eventually
this guy's going to mess up his career
that's what he would say so they would
look at a lot of stars like for himself
he was coming up they thought he was
going to be a big star and you know mlb
all-star play very quickly they realized
you're good for ml you're good for aaa
you're good for college but you're going
to make it in the he says i knew very
quickly i don't belong in this league
john knew he belonged in the league but
i wonder like you know sometimes you're
hanging out and i remember being in the
army
one weekend these guys are like we're
gonna go and party at this place i just
got this gut feeling like dude i'm just
not gonna go with these guys i'm just
not getting a good feeling about these
guys going where they're going so i
didn't go that weekend everybody got
arrested everybody went to jail
everybody was dishonorably discharged
that one weekend
so is it
the dna in him
is it he learned it from somebody is it
the friends is it the coach
who where do you put it it's in him okay
that's in his god he's got he's got that
wild side to him you know there's a part
see see the same things that make you
great
in one area will make you not so great
in the other area you know what i'm
saying and the fact that you know he
takes risk in a cage and he he lives
like that you know he he he takes risk
in his life too you know and um
it it's uh it's part of
is part of who he is you know i think
there are some things that he needs to
sort out within himself you know and i
feel that he's
he's he's doing those things but you
know
being able to do those things and being
able to confront a very uh ugly side of
yourself is confronting it you know what
i'm saying and being open and honest
about it to the point where you know
you're willing to deal with it and i
feel like he still needs to make strides
in that area you know being accountable
for the things that that actually you
know keep bringing him back to that
place and i feel like
as he grows even more you know because
he's not the same kid he was when he's
making no mistakes he's still making
those mistakes because he wasn't
accountable for it because he was 34 now
i mean yeah it's a different ballgame
it's a different ball game and here and
here's the sad thing and here's what i
do not want for him i do not want him to
still
be making those mistakes
once there's no value in him anymore
once people don't you know can't get
another penny out it's rough because at
that point
then you go down a whole different
spiral different spiral you know and
that's what i i don't hope for i hope
that he um
he figures it out because there's
something in him that's causing him to
keep going back to that place and he is
the only person that can sort that out
does does he does he have guys like you
in his ears like do you guys you sound
like a lot of dif a lot different
relationship today than the way you guys
were speaking eight years ago yeah you
know what i'm saying you sound and the
way you're speaking about him so have
you guys mended have you guys spoken
have you guys hung out have you guys
broken bread have you guys gone to
dinner is there that relationship again
um we don't have that relationship but
you know whenever i see him i speak to
him and say what's up to him and you
know give him some well wishes and
things like that you know i'm nothing
but love for the guy you know um you
know uh you know there's a couple times
i had some dreams about it i'm like oh
man i gotta check on john so i'll call
his manager malkie and like hey is john
okay i just had this crazy dream that
you know this happened to him you know
chuckling make sure that he's good you
know because
you know i i care about the kid you know
what i'm saying
and i don't want him to
uh i want him to be
the guy that he can be i want him to be
that guy
you you ever uh uh like even coming up
you know in the in the world of business
i've been around a lot of guys that were
10 times better than me in insurance
right
but you'd sit there and you talk i'd
watch like we're in a room say somebody
that's doing very well for themselves
they're giving counsel to us right
i'd watch
the other guys that i was in the same
camp with so imagine like an ultimate
fight or whatever but we're in an
ultimate fighter but for insurance and
business right
and one of the guys in the room just
looked at everybody like with the smirk
on his face like dude i'm 10 times
better than all you guys you guys have
no clue what you're talking about i know
what i'm you could never give this
person counsel and god forbid if you did
the level of sensitivity to the roof
oh my gosh you like get uncomfortable
like you know you know what i'm talking
about
there's no way a guy gets that good
without having taken coaching from
somebody
do you know what i'm saying like there's
no way you're born with those abilities
so he must have the ability to take the
coaching
in areas that he wants to
but the other side where you know a
cormier says he'll never change do you
agree with cormier that he'll never
change certain things
um
i don't agree with that you know i think
that uh i think that people can change
all the time and i feel like it just
takes the right situation to make that
change happen you know um i'm not the
person who i was 10 years ago in so many
different aspects not even five years
ago you know i've changed in so many
different ways and and that change
happened within me but it took me
realizing it you know no one could make
me change it was something that i needed
to see for myself to have that change
happen and you never know what happens
in life you know life can pull you in a
different you know direction and you
know uh have you see something that you
didn't see before and then you change as
a person yeah listen
this is coming from a fan you know you
you know from a fan perspective you want
to see this guy figure it out because
the guy is
he's got he's got michael in them
but he's got rodman in them
maybe a little dwight goodman so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]